Oh, hit that freeze.
Oh oh, you got a freeze?
Wait, is that part of your special
-or you found it?
-Those are the power moves, dawg.
-You don't know about the power moves?
-Oh f***.
So today, uh, Joe and I
will be playing Twisted Metal: Black™
from 2001 on a PS4.
I insisted on it, I like the better graphics.
I was like, "I want it to look worse."
What do you think about that?
Yeah well, that explains a lot on the show. Alright here we go.
We've come to the Q&A,
where I ask the Qs, or I kick your A.
-You've played all the Twisted Metal...
-I did, I did.
-I played 1 through Black™, and uh,
-Wow.
-it was one of the big co-op games that I think
-Sure.
brought together a lot of people, my friends at least,
so it has a fond place in my heart.
This is gonna be fun!
Machete!
-Who are you, who are you choosing?
-I have chosen Sweet Tooth.
We gotta talk about the car, 'cause like,
every car has been an ice cream truck in some form.
-Nice chain gun, you know like,
-Yes.
-I think the chain gun is pretty iconic to the car too, I mean...
-Oh, 100%.
Time to play!
-You and I are going head to head.
-Yes we are.
Okay, I'm on, I'm on bottom.
There was a moment where, uh,
we're in the sand dunes to shoot some Vegas stuff,
-and the ice cream truck literally almost flips.
-Yep.
You know, putting myself in harm's way is nothing new,
and uh, I did a lot of my own stunts.
I know there's one terrifying thing that
I think it was one of the last things that we shot--
Oh my God, yeah yeah yeah.
But uh, I was up on the hood of the car
and I was pounding on the glass,
-and then proceeded to smash it in.
-I mean, it was insane.
And then remembered, with terror, that uh,
Thomas Haden Church was still in the car.
-What the f***?
-And I remember I jumped off and opened up the door
and there's Thomas kinda frozen like, shaking his head,
and I'm, "I'm sorry! I'm sorry!" and he's like,
"Uh, it's alright, it's alright. We're good kid."
So sick of that f***ing clown!
Sweet Tooth has always wanted to have fans
and he's always wanted to
that's what he's kinda wishing for and
that's kinda what takes him on his journey, really.
Needless to say he had
some childhood trauma that led him to where he was--
Yeah, exactly, exactly,
-But uh--
-which is I'm really excited for fans to see.
Oh yeah, yeah. I'm really excited too.
-Did you get me? Damn!
-I won.
Getting a chance to come in and do Twisted Metal,
which is an iconic franchise,
for me as a gamer it's like,
it's weight you gotta carry on your shoulders because,
you know, you understand how gamers think,
you understand what gamers want so,
-we wanted to recapture the fun
-Yeah.
of couch co-op, of sitting there
with your buddies and talking trash and you know,
seeing the hits, "Ah!", and do our best
to kinda replicate that on the television screen.
Absolutely.
You know, I remember seeing your audition
because when we watched yours, it was like,
"Oh they're our Sweet Tooth."
There was absolutely no question.
I don't really know how to feel about that but you know.
-Ooh ooh, ow ow ow, ooh.
-Ooh!
-That took me down, g*****n!
Wow, perfect ten too.
I gotta... was that, was that a trophy?
Yeah you got a trophy. Well done.
Thank you, you are too kind.
Joe's wrestling and knowing what he can do physically
was just like, exactly what we were looking for.
We have Will Arnett voicing Sweet Tooth, which is amazing.
Put 'er there!
Firm grip you got there, Stu.
Bet you have a lot of fun with that.
For me, it was a blast to portray a character like this
who's just so off the rails.
But there definitely wasn't any restrictions
what you're putting out there for Will
because you know that he's gonna match it
and uh... it's gonna be awesome.
Surprise!
Ooh!
He was waiting for the questions.
He was waiting for the questions!
-I was like, "why don't you take this one?"
-Yeah yeah yeah,
"Why don't you take this one Joe?"
What was it like working with Stephanie and Anthony?
Awesome. You know, you couldn't ask for two better people
uh, you know, especially for
a uh... a newer actor as myself to work with, I mean
a lot of fun.
Some of the fight scenes we had in the casino
uh... were definitely a lot of fun, especially with Anthony
and his propensity to uh, throw himself
on objects and make people think that I'm
-shoving, tossing him around the room.
-Oh my God, yeah.
Oh, hi there!
Aw, that tickled.
I think all the stuff we shot
that was supposed to be the Vegas desert
was really fun. I mean, it was really hot. It was--
Oh no, oh no! Awwww, well done!
Take the question kid! Take those questions!
Damn it!
DAAAAAAMN!
OHHHHH NOOOOO!
OHHHHHHHHH!
-Good game.
-Damn.
-You got me, you got me that last time.
-Yeah. I got one, yeah.
-That was a pretty good move.
-I just had to trap you against that building.